paying too much money to see a doctor
getting charged crazy amounts just for
routine procedures and trying to figure
out exactly what is covered by your
insurance why is the health care system
in the u.s. so broken most countries in
the world have some form of universal
health care sometimes called
single-payer because everybody pays into
it everybody benefits from it sort of
like public schools or public
transportation basically you take away
private insurers and the government runs
the insurance program and so the
government is the single payer in the
u.s. the idea of universal healthcare
has always been a non-starter especially
on the federal level but it's quickly
picking up steam among young Americans a
recent poll showed forty five percent of
people between 18 and 29 support
single-payer and 66 percent of young
Democrats more and more people are
realizing that that we can't stay on
this trajectory millennial generation is
the highest level of uninsured in the
country not only do we not have access
to employer plans on an increasing level
we also don't have the money that our
parents generation had in terms of real
wages as enthusiasm around the idea
continues to grow some states aren't
waiting for Congress but when New York
California and Vermont tried to enact
their own versions of universal health
care in the last few years their efforts
failed but there's one state where some
think it just might work
Maryland and there's one candidate for
governor who's betting on it if we want
to unlock opportunity in our states
we've got to fix the health care system
there's no state that's ever been in a
better position than us to make
single-payer happen why might Maryland
be different
well most notably the state tends to be
left-leaning with twice as many
registered Democrats as Republicans
Maryland also has the highest median
income in the u.s. which means more
people with money who can pay into the
system Canada started with one prophet
standing up and saying that we will do
but Marilyn can be--that stay here we
have the will we've already shown that
was you move in this direction we can
save hundreds of millions of dollars Ben
Jealous
isn't alone in embracing single-payer
for his election campaign gubernatorial
candidates in Iowa California
Massachusetts and Michigan among others
are all running on a medicare-for-all
type platform why is this game to
traction because of the pain in our
society and we've hit a place where
health care's become so expensive and
this is exerting so much pressure not
just on working families but on small
businesses that we that something's
gonna give but single payer advocates
aren't so sure this could actually
happen in Maryland or they trying to
solve this on the state level is
necessarily even the right approach you
can really only do it at the national
level because there's so many national
laws and policies that are they get in
the way that it even if you passed a
bill that looked something like
single-payer you would then be find
yourself trying to get waivers from the
federal government until recently
campaigning on a single-payer health
care platform might have been political
suicide but things are changing Bernie
Sanders is Medicare for all plan last
year garnered 15 Senate co-sponsors
including some potential presidential
contenders just two years earlier he
couldn't even find one
I think it's notable that every Democrat
who wants to be president who's in the
US Senate has signed on to Bernie
Sanders bill there's a big battle that's
gonna be be played out in the Democratic
Party over health care the country has
been activated mean we all watch what
happened when Trump tried to get rid of
the Affordable Care Act and there were
thousands of people down in Washington
some people sitting in so disabled
people being carried out of you know the
Senate House we're working just as hard
and in some cases harder for longer
hours but we're getting less we see that
money is being generated in this country
it's just going into the pockets of of
the super wealthy
you